with the video game industry reaching
new heights with every passing year
it has been an uphill battle meeting the
demand with supply
what used to be branded as a form of
entertainment which is often nonsensical
has now become a curry of many
professionals across the globe
thanks to this rise in esports culture a
small category of esports will be
featured in the 2025 olympics
much to the surprise of the general
public who never saw video games to be
anything more than a leisure activity
with so much capital being invested in
this industry the development of these
games have their own career trajectory
and
one of the most exciting prospective
roles in the market today
starting from coding at its base level
to complex machine learning algorithm
might it speak
video game development has a lot of
potential for growth due to the variety
of languages one can
learn to be able to contribute
so hey everyone this is biaber from
simply learn
and welcome to this video on the best
programming language for gaming
before we get started let's understand
the metrics behind the rise in esports
culture
according to a business insider article
the esports industry is on track to be a
1.5
industry by 2023. this growth has been
accentuated
by the fact that a multitude of academic
institutions now provide scholarships
to those people looking to pursue a
career in video games
and represent their organization
professionally
as you can see the infographic the
growth in advertising revenue during
esports events have been growing at a
rapid rate
from 143 million in 2018 to 226 million
in 2020
video games have found prominence in the
daily household
it is said that 3 out of every 5
americans have either a sony playstation
an xbox or a personal computer built
specifically for gaming
such a high audience invites higher
sales figures which in turn generated
industry topping revenues you can see
the rate of growth getting stabilized as
we move into the 2020s
indicating an onset of esports culture
normalization
which will most likely see it take one
of the top revenue generating streams
in the recreational sector it's not just
about the people though
thanks to this new era of digital sales
and easy access to gaming consoles
reputed game developers like electronic
arts ubisoft
and bethesda have constantly managed to
rack up higher production budgets
in some of these game titles the
production cost is more than in some
hollywood movies
starting from hiring voice actors and
animators to finding programmers and
investing in marketing this kind of
splurge of cash has been made possible
purely due to the consistent return of
investment in games like gta 5
and destiny not every ambitious project
will get enough praise in the industry
but companies pay good money to make
sure they hit the right formula as often
as they can
thus increasing the necessity of
efficient game developers
with the right foundation and
programming one can take the first step
to become a sought after name in the
video gaming industry
thankfully this video is here to give
you a primer on the right programming
language to choose for your career
let's have a look at what we are going
to learn today we first learn what is
video game development
then move on to the top programming
languages in the market to start coding
games on
we also look at some of the honorable
mentions when it comes to languages that
just miss the cut
then have a demonstration on how we can
create a game using python
so let's understand about what game
development is
video game development is the art of
creating a game
rise from its design development all the
way to its release
it has various aspects throughout the
development cycle artifact design
good user experience balanced game
mechanics
realistic animations and voice acting a
reliable network profile
among many other things
the highlights include the process of
designing the look and behavior of games
all the menus to all the maps that are
included in the game need to be designed
by certain animators and graphic
designers
that work together as a team in certain
sects of the game
we also have reliable artifact designing
to the voice model
which help in giving life to the game
while programming is not exactly
compulsory to learn game development
it is essential in certain segments for
example
while designing the look and behavior of
the games or the sound designs
programming is not as important however
when depending on the behavioral aspect
of some game engines
programming is a must
while many of these departments don't
need programming things like mechanics
input configuration and networking setup
can all be programmed from a single guy
to teams dispersed all around the globe
depending on the scope of the project
to help reduce the load for certain
developers game engines have been
created
they act as a set of pre-configured
modules and mechanics
to accelerate the process of game
development
engines also help in easy distribution
among different platforms
thereby reducing the workload of the
development team by a considerable
amount
engines like unity cryengine and unreal
engine have revolutionized the way games
are developed today
and engines like these keep pushing the
boundaries of what we can expect over a
single framework
there isn't just a single department
that manages the complete cycle of the
game development
it is the joint effort so let's see some
of these individual teams
the input management team has a lot of
responsibility
in creating a responsive environment for
the user to play in
this theme programs the kind of input
parameters to be used
all the way to the game reacts to
movements actions
and interactions
the animation and design team is
supposed to be responsible for the first
impression that people have when they
see the game for the first time
be due to terrific graphics in the
trailers or an immersive gameplay
experience
thanks to an open world the design team
holds a lot of weight in deciding
which way the game should proceed
the sound production team handles all
the voice acting and the game response
in order to generate the best auditory
output
some video game titles have managed to
capture the atmosphere and war
much more accurately than some hollywood
movies
apart from in-game production a solid
voice acting lineup helps
build credibility into the story and the
inverse of it leaves a sour taste
in the mouth that is irrespective of the
great graphics of the responsive
gameplay
behavioral optimization teams handle the
response of the games to user decisions
it can be simple condition based
programming or complex machine learning
algorithms that learn the user's habits
throughout the playing process
to deliver a much more personalized and
authentic gaming experience
now that we understand the basics of
programming in game development
let's see which languages are the most
preferred when starting out with game
development
the languages we are going to cover in
this video are c sharp
c plus plus java
javascript and lua
c-sharp is one of the most widely used
languages in the video game industry
thanks to its unique xna framework xna
framework is a set of tools and runtime
environments
developed by microsoft thanks to this
framework
c-sharp is very popular when it comes to
developing games for windows operating
systems
and xbox consoles the famous unity
engine was written using c
sharp to encourage new people in taking
a video game development as a career
instead of running through heaps of
codes as an amateur
c-sharp is used along with other
languages such as c plus plus and java
to create a fully functional game
platform ready for release
some of the most famous titles to be
written in c hash
are the popular multiplayer game rust
and the classic stardew valley
speaking of c plus plus it is still the
most basic language needed for game
development
even after decades of its arrival it's
very fast
and compilation is surprisingly quick
even for large products with multiple
modules being side loaded
since c plus plus has been in the
industry for so long it has found its
way
into almost every platform that can run
games and is easy to run across
different systems
the modular nature of c plus also helps
in better management of memory and cpu
resources
thereby improving the overall
performance and user experience of the
game
it was a major part of the development
of game engines like unreal engine
and frostbite engine which are still
being used extensively in today's
industry
as flagship development platforms
the most popular games written on c plus
plus can be attributed to the frostbite
game fifa series
or the unreal engine game hallmark those
are the borderland games series
java found its way onto the game
development scene with the introduction
of the mobile phone
starting from the old motorola phones to
the thick nokia handsets
java has been prevalent since then and
is a crucial part of development
java gets compiled on a java virtual
machine or a jvm
this helps in decreasing the reliance on
a machine specification
and makes it much more scalable java
also has a multi-threading feature
that allows it to run multiple threads
of a single cpu simultaneously
this earns a significant boost in
productivity and performance
it may not be as instrumental in today's
desktop caliber games
but mobile based applications still
feature java at some level in their code
base
some popular games that employ java in
their codes are runescape
and the popular multiplayer game known
as minecraft
javascript on the other hand is a much
more suited to games that run on the
browser level
since it is already used for website
development integrating gaming mechanics
into the latest web technologies is
easier
this is possible due to the vast amounts
of libraries available for javascript
and a huge support community that has
been building it since the last decade
the well-known games in this javascript
sector are angry birds
and the game known as bejeweled
lua is a relatively quick and
cross-platform scripting language used
in game development
the language is very easy to learn
thanks to its easy syntax
and beginner-friendly language rules a
big bonus when it comes in developing
lua
is the ability to modify game files many
models take a lot of effort into adding
extra content to a complete game
as per the request of the community
according to a survey conducted by
gamedev.net in 2003
lua was found to be the most popular
scripting language being used for game
development
lua finds its use in the development of
popular games such as
roblox and baldur's gate
apart from these languages there are a
few honorable mentions that i feel we
should look into
that got overlooked in the above list
we have all heard about python it can be
used for both development and scripting
purposes
the main advantage of using python is
its pygame module
that acts as a quick prototyping
mechanism instead of running through a
lot of machines for testing purposes
unfortunately the scope of game
development in python has a lower
ceiling than the other languages we
discussed before
the games which are written using python
are usually simple in both design
and function while also being two
dimensional in gameplay these factors
prevent python from being the single
used language of a highly acclaimed game
title
it is used along with other languages
like c and c
plus plus to create a unified game
catering to all the needs of the player
python also finds use in training
machine learning models to be used in
video game development
to create a much more personalized
gaming experience
as compared to the general development
paradigms
apart from python kotlin has become a
new language to go for
as a replacement for java based
platforms it is mostly used for
developing android games
thanks to this google's very own android
studio
allows using kotlin to develop android
applications and games instead of java
some of the reasons people are jumping
to kotlin is because of the coding
efficiency
and much better memory management code
length in kotlin is much smaller than
java for the same output
while many people are starting to prefer
coating over java for newer projects
the community and bug squashing support
is still far from the heights of java
so it is going to be a good while till
you see cortland take over the mobile
development scenario completely
now that we get an idea of how unique
each programming language is when it
comes to game development
let's take a look at one example where
you can understand how the games are
created on a very small scale
i use python for this demo and the
application being run is the classic
snake game
let's jump in
i will be using the software pie chart
which is a development environment for
python
we use this environment for coding the
game functionality as well as testing it
as a prototype
before i proceed i would like to make
you aware that python needs to be
installed on the machine before start
writing code along with pie chart or
does any other software which can
compile python code
now when we jump into the code my first
step is to import the libraries being
used
while developing the game python has a
huge library of
extensions that can be imported into its
programs in order to gain certain
functionality
in this case i am importing three
modules namely turtle
time and random turtle is a
pre-installed python library that
enables users to create pictures and
shapes
by providing them with a virtual canvas
the on-screen pen that you use for
drawing is called the turtle
and this is what gives the library its
name in short
the python turtle library helps new
programmers get a feel
for what programming with python is like
in a fun and interactive way
the time module is used to count the
number of seconds elapsed since the
epoch
while the random function can be used to
generate random numbers in python
we use a set of predetermined variables
to be used along with the program
in our first segment we create a window
screen
this is done by using the turtle module
this helps in giving a background to the
game
on which we can turn up our controls and
other graphical enhancements
in the second part we create the head of
the snake
this will be our control for the entire
game and it will
change the direction on which direction
we want to go
the next part we design the food of the
game all of this can be done using the
turtle module
and in some parts the random module as
well which helps to determine where the
food will be appearing on the screen
the next part is assigning control
variables in the assigning control
variables part we need to assign
local variables and global variables to
be used when we provide input while
playing the game
all of these can be used using the
turtle module and here
we can assign the keys that are being
used to assign the
controls we have given the w s a
d commands to go for the top bottom left
and right commands respectively
after the commands are set we need to
focus on the main gameplay of the portal
the main gameplay will handle the score
management the way the size of the snake
increases after eating the food
and the way the game ends when the snake
hits a barrier
or body itself all this can be done in
the final part
which leads to the final output of the
game let's take a look at the result
as you can see we have initiated a
proper full working python game
using a single page of code this can be
controlled using the wsd key as we
mentioned
which are customizable and can be done
in any format possible
it has the backgrounds it has colors
which can be changed
and we also have a high score mechanism
that gets updated
if we lose or continue playing
apart from the visuals we have also have
sound libraries imported into the game
to make it more life like
albeit in a snake game that makes a less
of an addition
so this is how we can use python to get
started on
generic game development using just
turtle and a few other modular functions
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
regarding the topic that we mentioned
feel free to post your questions in the
comment sections and we will happy to
get back to you
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here